A primeira forma de aprender, sem dúvida, é criando projetos do mundo real.
Se você quer aprender Cloud Code, vem aí o desafio Cloud.
Quatro dias, quatro projetos do mundo real.
Projetos de todas as áreas.
Marketing e vendas, financeiro e contabilidade, operação e logística.
Se você quer trabalhar nas principais áreas do mercado de trabalho,
seja estar buscando um stage, primeiro emprego, uma promoção,
em algum momento vão te perguntar como você tem trabalhado com Cloud Code.
E saber essa habilidade não é mais opcional.
Então, venha participar.
Vamos ser somente em quatro dias que eu vou te ensinar a habilidade mais importante em 2026.
O ano está acabando, mas você tem que fazer ele valer a pena.
Clica aqui, estou te esperando.